in October right before this started  happening that I realized that the  nationalist and mental health and the  Department of Defense in the VA we're  not going to give us a penny even though  FDA had said it's a breakthrough  even though they have a massive problem  with PTSD yeah but well it's the stigma  of these drugs it seems like the VA is  stigma of the drugs just isn't there's a  reason also on top of money it's about  the persecution of minorities I mean if  we look at you know look at Florida  where Bush got elected and where which  went for Trump and they have arrested  loads and loads of african-americans who  tend to vote Democratic and once you get  a felony arrest then you can't vote in  Florida are you so it's called felony  disenfranchisement yeah